There is something I need, if I am to rule
Mandalore.
Something that was once mine.
They know where it is. and soon, so will I.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This is going to be my new Mandalorian season
2 Bo Katan and darksaber video all explained
what's going on with them on the series.
Katie sackhoff also clarified some things
in a recent interview that she did about what's
going on with the future of her character.
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
So if you're brand-new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all those and
we'll do a giveaway for Disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and post all your theories about Bo Katan
in the darksaber on the video careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened on
the Mandalorian.
So far all just number these as we go along
to stay organized starting with number 10
Bo Katan tells the Mandalorian that she's
changing the deal Darth Vader style big Empire
strikes back reference pray I don't alter
it further.
This is the way because she did need the weapons
Moff Gideon was buying in order to arm her
divisions Mandalorian's that she explains,
so she could eventually retake Mandalorian
from all of his forces, but in order to actually
be able to rule the Mandalorian people effectively.
She also needed something special that thing
of course was the darksaber because they're
incorporating more cannon from the Star Wars
clone wars and Rebels series and she literally
shouts it out later in the episode.
The darksaber is been a relatively recent
addition to the Star Wars Canon the last 10
years or so, but within the Mandalorian culture.
It's been used as a symbol of leadership for
a thousand years of her to truly become the
new Mandalorian the leader of their reunified
people.
Because are scattered right now.
She needs to have it for all to see is like
being a king or queen without a crown you
might be a leader, but most of the people
won't really recognize her respect you without
all the flare in the trappings of Kings and
Queens and for Mandalorian's that just means
swinging around the darksaber number nine.
That's why her older sister.
Duchess sateen Crees had trouble leaving the
Mandalorian's during the clone wars, she was
more of a pacifist and wanted to take her
people away from their militaristic ways which
did not sit well with a lot of the traditionalist
factions within their people there a very
warlike culture.
Historically and when Bo Katan told man dough
that he was a child of the watch the deathwatch
like in the flashback we saw him get rescued
by the deathwatch Mandalorian's from the clone
wars their group was an extreme example of
a growing sentiment in the Mandalorian culture
that they should return to the old ways of
their people and become conquerors again the
way they explained deathwatch in the series
here is that their sort of like this crazy
religious called the deathwatch of the clone
wars wasn't quite so crazy but Duchess sateen
did not have the darksaber pre-biz love.
Jon Favreau's character did he was the leader
of the deathwatch.
He was also a direct descendent of one of
the original leaders of their people Mandalorian
the great, the one that keep referring to
during season one.
The original Mandalorian Jedi, who created
the darksaber in the first place.
Then came back to lead his people.
His name was Tarre Viszla he died about a
thousand years ago, so he never knew original
Yoda adjuster of charting big moments in the
timeline.
It was about 900 years old when he died, so
he didn't come along to little bit later but
him having the pedigree in the darksaber heavily
undermined Duchess sateen's efforts at peace
with the republic Jedi number 8 Bo Katan herself
was briefly a member of the deathwatch.
But before that she created the night owls
with sateen.
That's why they have those white owl symbols
on their armor.
Here they were originally just meant to be
an elite group of female warriors, but one
of the reasons why Bo Katan join pre viszla
and deathwatch was because at the time part
of her believed his way the old way might
be better, at least for a time until she realize
how crazy he wasn't starting to get and then
he was killed by Darth Maul who then hijacked
the Darksaber their group and try to take
over the entire planet number seven.
She also mentions that the end of the episode
as she's interrogating Titus Welliver's captain
character.
They didn't really give him an actual name
in the episode.
They just call him the captain in the credits
she asked them if he has the Darksaber.
He activated his own personal kill switch
there, so to speak, to prevent Bo Katan from
forcing him to take her directly to Moff Gideon,
but obviously that's who they were talking
about everyone saw him with the darksaber
at the end of season one episode eight cutting
himself out of the Thai outlander, and just
before the scene.
He showed up on the comms ordering the captain
and is meant to destroy the shipment of weapons.
Number six Katie sackhoff did a bunch of interviews
in the past week after episode three aired
talking about how she became live-action Bo
Katan jet.
She said that was harder do the live-action
version.
After having done the voice of animated Bo
Katan just because she wanted to get it.
So perfect and so accurate to the animated
version.
She said that she didn't have any scenes with
Asoka this season, but that she hopes to have
some scenes with her in future seasons just
sort of confirming what's going to be happening
with Asoka the season.
She also says that when she was developing
the live-action version.
She had long conversations with Jon Favreau
and Dave Filoni about Bo Katan's history between
the clone wars rebels when she shows up here
and episode three years later and what their
plans were for her live-action version in
the future of the Mandalorian series in the
Star Wars universe in general.
She did kind of address some of the spinoff
rumors to all explained that at the end of
the video, but yes of course it should go
without saying that she's going to come back
in future episodes.
Number five.
More importantly she also said that they will
reveal how Moff Gideon actually got the Darksaber
from her during the season 2 episodes.
We will have to wait till season three to
find that out.
We haven't seen much of Moff Gideon during
season 2, so far episode for this week is
going to be the halfway point this season.
So just confirms that I'll be a ton more Moff
Gideon in the back half Giancarlo Esposito
said that he broke a ton of the Darksaber
props on set while they were filming lightsaber
fight scenes the Darksaber just a different
type of specialized lightsaber to be clear,
Darksaber just what everyone calls it because
of the black blade that obvious implies is
going to be chopping his way through at least
a couple people in close combat and we might
actually get to see Bo Katan come within arms
reach of the Darksaber during season to but
based on the way Giancarlo Esposito talked
about his story during the season.
In his interviews it doesn't sound like anyone
is going to be able to take the Darksaber
from him.
At least this season future seasons for sure.
That's the whole arc of the series the Mandalorian's
eventually reclaiming their planet from him
in everything that he stole from them.
Number four originally Bo Katan was given
the darksaber by Sabina Wren during Star Wars
rebels, so that she could unify the remaining
Mandalorian clans under a single banner.
This is Emperor palpitating in the Empire
were finishing their conquest of the galaxy.
This is all during the rise of the Empire
taking place about a year before the events
of a New Hope in the original trilogy of movies
after this.
The only thing we know for a character is
that she fights in the great purge loses the
Darksaber to Moff Gideon.
Somehow, which still explained during season
2 episodes.
Then she the night owls become pirates, so
to speak, gathering weapons to arm their scattered
Mandalorian people and mount a new war to
retake the planet.
Then she shows up and episode three really*it
will completely cover her entire history.
During that missing.
The original trilogy during season to but
like she said they will explain how Moff Gideon
got the Darksaber the rest of that history
the place slowly dole out in future seasons
when she comes back or appears and potential
spinoff series when she talked about the potential
spinoff series that she would show up on she
just gave the standard blanket I don't know
what you're talking about spinoff series,
but obvious he the Disney CEO said that they
were developing spinoff series in the Mandalorian,
number three before Bo Katan have the Darksaber
the first time it appeared was during the
clone wars season 2.
Jon Favreau played a character called Pre
Viszla that I've talked about a bunch during
my videos.
The reason why he came to the series.
Jon Favreau was because he was finishing editing
on the first Ironman movie back in 2007 Skywalker
Ranch while at the same time, date for Loney
was working on the clone wars they became
friends in real life.
Eventually, Dave Filoni says why don't you
come play character on my TV show the clone
wars, so they created Pre Viszla for him,
but because he was going to be facing off
against Obi-Wan the Jedi Duchess sateen they
wanted to give him something that would make
him just as bad ass is a potential Jedi.
So Dave Filoni and George Lucas created the
concept of the Darksaber and that's where
you see it show up in this episode here.
He was eventually killed by Darth Maul who
then took the Darksaber will that it for a
while then Maul took the Darksaber to death
the mirror where it rested till Star Wars
rebels when they grabbed it backs to being
got it then and then eventually she gave it
to Bo Katan Sam Witwer the voice of Darth
Maul also is been posting a bunch of memes
on twitter just joking about the Darksaber.
I don't know where this came from.
This belongs to meet was stolen out of my
bedroom.
There's so many different characters that
he could play in these live-action series,
he himself could be a version of star killer.
He can also come back as the voice of Darth
Maul during the Obi-Wan series as has been
rumored, but number two, when Bo Katan was
talking about retaking Mandalorian that was
what she was referring to when she said that
they were taking the entire ship not just
the weapons will need this in the battles
to come.
That sounds like a teaser for something further
off in future seasons still definitely be
a big battle before the season 2 finale, but
she's talking about this grand war to retake
the entire planet and that's a classic Star
Wars style giant space battle way too big
for single episode, so early prediction the
battle for Mandalorian or the new battle for
Mandalorian will be something that they spread
out over the course of the entire final season
of the show or final seasons multiple whatever
those wind up being season four season five
season seven I would love to see the Mandalorian
series go for seven seasons and in the Disney
CEO said they were developing multiple Mandalorian
spinoff series with different characters.
That new Galactic level war for Mandalorian
would probably cross over into the plots of
those other series as well, number one.
It should be said that the Mandalorian will
always be the main series, no matter how many
spinoff series.
They do is a game of thrones.
They slowly build to the war with the white
walker's the final seasons and eventual final
battle for Kings Landing the iron throne.
Now were just talking about the best car iron
throne of man to lower you just have to have
faith the Dave Filoni and Jon Favreau are
way better at adapting that story than the
game of thrones showrunner, so odds are pretty
good that everyone will be way happier with
how they decided to tell this full story.
As for the Mandalorian himself getting caught
up in this giant Galactic war.
He's the classic trope of the reluctant hero.
Not wanting to get involved in her war to
retake the planet know I had this mission.
This child have to take him back to the Jedi.
So he's doing everything he can to avoid getting
involved in these bigger conflicts but will
inevitably find himself inspired to join the
fight for a number of reasons, most notably
because early prediction Moff Gideon will
probably be able to capture baby Yoda maybe
with a little bit of help from Boba Fett and
when he tries to rescue him in season three.
He'll need all the help he can get help that
Bo Katan in the night owls the of the Mandalorian's
can give him, thus making him a bigger part
in their fight against Moff Gideon because
Bo Katan also wants to get rid of Moff Gideon
in a much bigger way.
So they both have beef with him.
So is just another reason for them to team
up again, but everyone post all your theories
in the comments below my full Mandalorian
season 2 episode four video will post Friday
just like normal and congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last big Star Wars
video Matthew Russell please email me on the
about page my channel so I can get your contact
details everyone click here for my brand-new
Mandalorian season 2 Asoka Tonto scene break
down and click here for my full Mandalorian
season 2 episode 3 video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the
way!